I mean it's wonderful love not to build
the wall but you need the wall and I
will tell you this the ice officers and
the Border Patrol agents I had them just
recently up they say if you don't have
the wall you know in certain areas
obviously that aren't protected by
nature if you don't have the wall you
cannot have security just get out it
doesn't work well got it welcome back to
Hannity here with reaction in my opening
monologue and the president's big
bipartisan meeting on immigration at the
White House today counsel to the
president Kellyanne Conway is back good
to see you Kellyanne here the president
put out this tweet earlier tonight and
he said building the wall and we heard
him over and over again it's imperative
I know that conservatives friends of
mine they doubt because they've been
promised again and again and again we
always get the consideration amnesty
never the wall we always get the type
the spending increase never the tax cut
now we have the tax cut people want to
see that wall they want to see some of
it by November everyone in that room
today everyone watching now knows where
the president stands on the wall he just
repeated it for you live and in person
in front of the entire world to see Sean
you know the wall is an imperative and
the wall the president made clear today
because he's talked to he's conferred
with those literally on the front lines
who want this wall we he asked the ice
ages he asked the Border Patrol agents
he asked those on the front lines what
they need secretary Neilson has asked
her folks what do you need to be able to
do your job to make us a more safe and
secure nation and they've all said we
need this type of security need a border
you know we have spent billions of
dollars over decades helping other
countries secure their own borders their
own sovereignty it's high time we did in
our country and this is the leader who
will make it happen Donald Trump I think
in the span of one hour today you saw in
fold the three major promises this
president has made to the country
security prosperity and trans
pairen see the transparency is obvious
even some of his greatest critics in the
media were flabbergasted really stunned
but appreciative that this president
held forth on camera for a full hour
with no filter no script for anybody
just a conversation bicameral bipartisan
unprecedented in that way in the Cabinet
Room secondly these security this
president knows his first obligation is
to keep us safe and secure in this
country you do that with a wall the wall
the southern border is 2,000 miles about
800 or so might be the physical wall
there are mountainous and river areas
where you can't put a physical structure
but you can put fencing you can have
technology you can put more agents there
it makes us more safe and secure people
are ready not crossing as much as they
did illegally because this man is
president because they know walls are
being built because they know that folks
are tougher we don't want the poison the
drugs coming over our board and we don't
want people here illegally through train
migration and the Visa Lottery and and
finally the prosperity economic security
and national security go hand-in-hand
and you see what's happening and with
this president his leadership his bold
actions along with that of the
Republicans in Congress and that massive
tax cut for the middle class they are
making this country more prosperous
consumer confidence unemployment levels
down for african-americans for teens for
Hispanics for women for all of America
all the confidence measures up national
security economic security go hand in
hand the wall is not negotiable the
Democrats came there today basically
saying doc is not negotiable give us a
clean dhaka bill the president said no
the wall doctor to be considered the
wall but also an entity and migration
which accounts for about nine point
three million resettlement that
resettled in the population a year but
you know one person is here and you get
about seven family members some setting
country send upwards of twenty members
when I showed at the tape of Chuck
Schumer then there's Bernie Sanders in
this Hillary Clinton then this Barack
Obama you know all these Democrats they
basically sound like Donald Trump but
now because Donald Trump supports that
they can't possibly support only if the
Anointed One Obama maybe if hope was
supported it they support it and so is
it just opposition to this president for
the sake of opposition
and the other point is all these days I
saw a president in command of the fax
leaning opening up transparency like
we'd never had before today and that's
what made it so fascinating it was and
those of us who work there see that
every day on a regular basis he really
enjoys a discussion he and he welcomes
dissent and he welcomes discussion this
president takes many different inputs
and ideas and he makes the final
decision he was the one elected here
after all but I think what you saw on
full display today is is very similar to
what we see in an ongoing basis at this
White House
and let me let me just say this when you
ask what's different now sure what's
different for these Democrats including
Hillary Clinton they are crowing and
bragging about how much she doesn't
think we should have people crossing
illegally and we should have borders and
wow she should have said that in 2016
she might have made some of those states
more competitive
although anyway we would have won anyway
but the fact is that what's changed is
number one they have a president who's
willing to actually do it and just like
with these tax cuts just like when you
were grieving the embassy to Jerusalem
people have promised it but they never
thought they'd have a president will do
it number two they are beholding many
them to special interest and this is a
president is talking about what
additional interest not special
interests last question quick answer
we're running out of time for 2018 isn't
it good for the Republican Party to be
able to say see we're keeping our
promise we have two or three hundred
miles of the wall done now take a look
at it we meant it we we got it done no
doubt we didn't get here overnight we
know the wall can be built overnight but
people seeing that it is happening that
you have a physical wall you also have
technology you have fencing in places
where a physical wall cannot happen and
most importantly you end the chain
migration the diversity Visa Lottery and
you show people about that southern
border that we have more ice agents
there we need to empower these men and
women with the tools they need to do
their jobs
alright Killian thanks for staying up
late I know you're always up early we
appreciate it when we come back